okay so the next tuck last tuck the
morning is by Liang Tang on pulling my
toes all right thanks I like the thing
to organize this for the opportunity to
speak this is trying to work with Ryan
O'Donnell at CMU and Rocco who's in the
audience so be concerned with the basic
object needs talk polytopes over the
discrete hypercube 0 1 to the end so
these are functions F that can be
described as intersections of
half-spaces F which are at the end of H
1 to H M and each H I is a half space
the sign of a linear form and would be
concerned with polytopes over the
discrete cube 0 1 to the N so these
objects come up all the time we think
computer science they show up all the
time the optimization the number of half
spaces normal facets correspond exactly
to number of constraints the in a 0 1
integer program they show up in
complexity theory and learning theory
and as we know they have been studied
beyond computer science and complete
oryx in high dimensional geometry and so
and so forth so in this talk we'll keep
things very simple that's just one
complexity measure will be concerned
with perhaps the most natural one the
number of facets so in other words it's
the number of half spaces if you write
it as the end of m half spaces our
reserved m to denote this quantity
throughout it's not too hard to see
since we are working over the discrete
cube M is a number between 1 & 2 to the
N and I would like to get as good a
dependence on M as possible in this talk
for concreteness we can think of em as
poly n say n to the 10th so we're
concerned with n-dimensional polytopes
with poly and many facets okay there are
many questions we can ask about
polytopes we'll focus on just one of
them in this talk that of constructing
discrepancy sets for polytopes
so what's the discrepancy set we want a
small set of points they're smaller the
better with the following very special
property so so here's my set of points
for every and facet polytope F F has
some true density with respect to the
cube F accepts a delta fraction of
inputs in 0 1 to the N I like it to be
case that for every such F if its
density is Delta it is true densities
Delta the fraction of my red dots that F
accepts is roughly Delta as well so it's
a small set of points that approximately
preserves the volume of every polytope
in 0 1 to the N so a quick observation
here is that this is a problem the name
of the game here is explicit
constructions
a random set off a small random set of
points works great the name of the game
here is a construct a small explicit set
oh yes many of us who have recognized
this exactly the problem of constructing
pseudo-random generators for M facet
polytopes so what I'm actually going to
do is to restate the question in a
slightly different language but it's
gonna be completely equivalent so just
to recall the standard definition an
epsilon PRG for class C is a function
explicit function stretching our random
bits to many many more bits such a no
function in a class can tell the
difference so if you feed a truly
uniform string to F in your class its
acceptance probability is roughly the
same as if you fed the output of your
generator to your class within some
error epsilon and we have designs you
don't end in January this for all sorts
of classes and this talk will focus on
the class of emphasis at polytopes so
here the dependence the seed length
could be a function of n the dimension M
the number of facets which we can think
of as n square n to the 10th and Epsilon
the error which we can think of as a
point 1 and up to an exponential the
number of random bits is precisely the
size of your discrepancy say it's not
allowed to see that the image of a PRG
is precisely a discrepancy set ok so
here's our main result we give an
epsilon PRG for the class of emphasis
polytopes
over n dimensions with seed length poly
log n poly in one of epsilon multiplied
by log in there's actually quite a bit
of work on this problem in various
special cases and I'll go into detail in
the next slide but for this general
version of the problem the previous pass
we banked have linear dependence on M so
the key here is the exponential
exponential improvement in nm so in
other words recalling this you know
equivalent view we give a explicit
construction of a discrepancy set of
size n to the poly log m whereas the
previous best construction had size n to
the M so there are only 2 to n points so
a trivial one is 2 to the N so it's this
this bound becomes trivial when M is
roughly n whereas for any M being any
poly n our our size is still quasi poly
in N and this is fixing epsilon to be
0.1 ok so that's that's all main result
great the random set is log n plus log n
plus log 1 over epsilon so we are within
polynomial our log independence is
optimal we are within polynomial optimal
for log n but we are exponentially off
in one over epsilon yeah you pre have
the my next slide okay so good okay let
me talk more about previous work here so
there's been quite a bit of work on this
let's focus on a dependence on M the
number of facets so recall that a
polytope is an intersection or the end
of m half spaces so work of Coquelin
I'll give a PRG for much richer class of
functions any function or just the end
of M general half-spaces however that
seedlings had a linear dependence on M
and it's not too hard to see that given
how rich this class is it certainly
contains every function on M variables
because a single variable is clearly a
half space you cannot hope to do you
can't hope to get C Bank better than
linear now however if you all you care
about what's the intersections of M
general half-spaces
you could hope to do better so then came
a pair of works focusing on the
intersection of M half-spaces and they
indeed they got this exponential win in
seedling for but under certain technical
conditions on half spaces so first work
was the intersections of M regular half
spaces the work of partial climates and
Mecca there's gonna be a very important
paper for us and this notion of
regularity is going to be very important
for us so you find it carefully soon for
now briefly a regular half space is one
for which the weights are very evenly
spread out so assuming the rater weights
are very evenly spread out they give
such a seed length and then for an
incomparable class off of half spaces
Rocco and I give a similar kind of seed
length this this notion is less
important for us so I'm not going to
define it and in this work we solve the
general problem we give a PRG for the
intersection of M general half-spaces
not assuming regularity in or deceiving
low witness with with the see length of
poly log and so in this sense it's
observes these two works but of course
we build quite heavily on the machinery
and the ideas in in huh Chicago and
Rebecca ok so let me just comment a
little bit on the other parameters but
I've really say what I want to say on
the last slide which is
that the epsilon dependence is still
exponentially off so a very nice open
problem which our cycle back is is to
get poly logarithmic dependence on one
of them as long even for these special
places as you can see our dependence in
poly and one of that stuff okay so
before diving in let me actually zoom
out and say that this fits into a line
of work on on these PR G's for geometric
objects so you can ask the same
questions about just a single half space
and by now we have a fairly good
understanding of the C length required
to fool a single half space in this work
we are exploring one generalization
where we are not dealing with just one
half space but n of M many half spaces
that's a different line of work which I
will not touch on but this is a
beautiful line of work exploring a
different kind of generalization it's
still a single function but rather than
a sign of a linear form you look at a
sign of a degree D form but we will
focus on this branch okay so this is
structure of my talk there are two parts
the first part has nothing to do with
our work well it's not our work yeah the
first of all I'd like to tell you about
beautiful connection between this
problem and central limit theorems it's
a very versatile and powerful framework
for for designing pseudo-random
generators from central limit theorems
introduced by Mac and Superman and
Harsha Kaiba's in Mecca and we'll see
that it's especially effective for
analyzing this class of regular
half-spaces and in fact one the main
points I hope to get across in the first
part of the talk is their central limit
theorems and this notion of regularity
really go hand in hand
okay then they'll bring me to our our
work which is moving beyond regularity
and I'll outline some of the challenges
in dealing with general half-spaces
they're not necessarily regular we will
use this framework but it requires us to
bring in new ideas and new ingredients
one of which which unfortunately I don't
think I have time for which I hope is
independently interesting is a new high
dimensional Littlewood offered in the
concentration inequality a new little
offer theorem for polytopes
but i'm happy to talk about this offline
or or at the end of the talk but so for
the first product in fact for the main
part of the talk I'm just gonna focus on
telling you about this very nice
connection between this this class of
problems and essential
so just a briefly recall right so
there's a first party and I'm gonna
focus on a on the example of fooling a
single just a single regular half-space
and we've seen just two slides finally
what this definition of regularity is it
just will quickly recall a central limit
theorem say that the sum of many nice
reasonable random variables for us this
would be in the notion of regularity
converges to a Gaussian of the same mean
and as variance as a sum each X I itself
may not look like a Gaussian but if you
sum many of them they start to look like
a Gaussian are they're mainly notions of
convergence in this talk will focus on
convergence in CDF distance or common
girl distance just a weight then s
places under any threshold is roughly
the same as the way that a Gaussian
places on any threshold as we'll see
this notion of convergence syncs up
perfectly with that of a half space a
half space outputs one if and only if
the linear form evaluates to a value
less than theta so this is really like
the the right notion to look at when you
deal with half spaces okay so let's look
at explicit central limit theorem the
barriers in central limit theorem is a
sort of a quantitative central limit
theorem so given an epsilon regular
linear form this is one a linear form in
which no weight is too dominant every
weights magnitude is at most an epsilon
fraction of the overall two norm this is
what a regular linear form means a good
example to keep in mind is probably when
all the weights are the same just think
of all WI sar1 in fact in this talk when
I say regular maybe just have in mind
that example of like majority when all
the weights are one that's the most
regular half space Epsilon there is one
over root n so given such a nice linear
form where all the weights are spread
out if you pump in bits as inputs the
sum looks like a Gaussian this epsilon
close to a Gaussian in CDF distance so I
guess epsilon here bounds the dislike
height of this little arrow triangle
here okay so that's the central limit
theorem just let me just make one
obvious but crucial remark which is this
this notion of regularity is crucial for
us it's some other very simple and
somewhat silly example but consider f of
X equals x1 there's a very non regular
linear
sort of the opposite of a majority here
X 1 W 1 is 1 epsilon is 1 so it's the
worst in terms of regularity and indeed
are the CDF of AB it looks nothing like
a Gaussian you need things to be spread
out for the central limit theorem to
kick in and we will revisit this
observation in our work and now assume
we are dealing with regular linear forms
ok so I've told you about central limit
theorems but what does that have to do
with the problem we are interested in
which is fooling linear forms fooling
sign of linear forms well suppose you're
given an epsilon regular just a fully
regular linear form s of X the CLT says
that you converge is a Gaussian in CDF
distance meeting s of X where X is
uniform the probability is roughly the
same as the mass is roughly the same as
what a Gaussian places under theta
that's what a CLT says what does it mean
to fool the linear form sign of f of X
minus theta it means to cook up a pseudo
random variable such the weight that f
of X where X is uniform places on the
theta it's roughly the same as what
would happen if you fed it pseudo random
bits instead of truly at random bits
that's what it means the fool that
half-space sine of s of X minus theta so
the left-hand sides are the same in one
case you're comparing it with a Gaussian
in the other case you're comparing it
with a pseudo random variable so given
this it sort of suggests that you'll be
very nice to have a pseudo random
version of the barrier same central
limit theorem if you had that you could
apply the triangle inequality
and get this so this observation that a
beautiful paper on mecha and Superman
made and they carry out this game plan
they wanted the design pseudo-random
generators for for regular half-spaces
they observed that the various in
central limit theorem tells you that f
of X converges in CDF distance to a
Gaussian they D randomized the
Berenstain central limit theorem they
cooked up a suitable pseudo-random Y
which I'll tell you about on the next
slide
such that even if you fed s you know the
pseudo-random why it's still convergence
in CDF distance to a Gaussian given this
picture using the Gaussian that's the
middle person they've shown this s of X
and s of Y a close in CDF distance and
it's exactly what it means to fool
sign of s of X minus theta for every
theta so this is how they got a PRG
really nice okay so let me tell you a
little bit about the generator the the
structure of the generator
they have n variables we want to use a
randomness efficient way of feeding
values to them they hash it into 1 over
epsilon squared many buckets
the quantitative parameters are perhaps
not super important for this talk the
hash it into 1 over epsilon squared many
buckets because there are so few buckets
they can afford to do this independently
across buckets independently across
buckets the assign the variables that
fall in that bucket
according to constant y's independent
distribution is there there's a
generator and what they were able to
prove was that you know even if you
assigned who I 1 to yn this way if you
sum them up in a regular way the sum
converges to a Gaussian like what you
expect if you assign them fully randomly
and by the triangle inequality it shows
that this distribution fools regular
half-spaces and it's not so hard to see
that you know the seed length you get
the only one of epsilon square in many
buckets and to generate a constant wise
independent distribution you need C
length roughly log n so this is a using
log n over epsilon square many random
bits I can assign values to n variables
such that when you sum them it looks
like a Gaussian I should say before
moving on that they do a lot more in
this paper it's really really nice paper
but this this this part is what's gonna
be most relevant for us
let's talk in fact all PR jeez you can
think of them as having this structure
hashed and variables in a synonym both
buckets the number of buckets meaning to
be larger and assigned values
independently across buckets according
to a que wise independent distribution
for some case so we may have the ramp of
the parameters but it has this general
structure and the analyses get more and
more complicated just one one one
sentence about this roughly speaking
they reduce to showing that each bucket
is a mega variable and they apply
barriers in to one over epsilon square
many independent mega variables very
nice okay so that's how the floor a
single regular half space you can think
okay now I like to food intersections of
M many regular half spaces where think
of M is N squared we'll see it's the
same overall framework but there are
many cool new conceptual and technical
new ideas and ingredients I'm just gonna
have time to highlight in fact just one
okay so we are given a polytope where
every facet is regular recall that the
key technology underlying the mecha
Zukerman paper for a single regular half
space was the central limit theorem if
you sum many real valued random
variables none of them are too dominant
it's a regular song it starts to look
like a Gaussian now we are dealing with
M many regular half-spaces so we'll need
an M dimensional central limit theorem
if you sum and many are M value random
variables m here the the dimension of
the vectors correspond exactly to the
number of half spaces you have you some
many many of these vectored very random
variables none of them are too dominant
in a sense that can be made precise then
it converges to a M dimensional Gaussian
and CDF distance and again here there
many notions of convergence the one that
they use and the one that's relevant for
that that this problem is that of
multi-dimensional CDF distance and just
as how CDF distance in one dimensions
exactly captures the acceptance
probability of a single half space
multi-dimensional CDF distance exactly
captures the acceptance probability of
an end of M half spaces so there's
really the right notion of of closeness
to look at
all problem so then my Tony intersection
another arbitrary function to get this
census just one authen
for arbitrary functions you need to
dream orphans yeah the question and in
fact they well yeah let's talk about
this offline you can get an arbitrary
function but you have to pay em in C
length yeah okay good so they prove this
this is nothing to do with your Animas
ation they prove this very nice central
limit theorem and they follow the same
game plan now instead of one regular
half-space I have M rectum of space
half spaces I'm gonna arrange them in a
matrix are M by n where every role of a
is regular the role every role is the
weight of a regular half space they
proved the multi dimensional barriers
and theorem showing that ax where X is
truly uniform converges to M dimensional
Gaussian they didn't just prove this
central limit theorem they also D
randomized it they showed that under
pseudo random why a Y is also CDF close
to the same M dimensional Gaussian so
they converge to the same Gaussian and
using this Gaussian as the middle person
you can say the ax and way why are CDF
close by the triangle inequality and
that's exactly what it means the food
intersection of half spaces specified by
a and what's why Y is exactly the Mecca
sukham and generator with different
parameters hash the variables into so
then I'm all buckets independent across
buckets assign it to K wise in penance
for some K initially under this
distribution a why start to look like M
dimensional Gaussian - ok great so this
is a really nice powerful versatile
framework a bridge established in these
two works hopefully though I will see we
have seen that notion of regularity is
very crucial to this framework even in a
one dimensional case so in my remaining
time let me talk about intersections of
general half-spaces so as alluded to the
main challenge even a one-dimensional
case is that the central limit theorem
simply does not hold when you're dealing
with non regular half-spaces if you have
a sum if the W is that dominant is just
not gonna look like a Gaussian and
recall this the same
or somewhat silly but example s of X
equals x1 x1 is very dominant a bit the
CDF does not look like that of any
Gaussian so this notion of regularity is
really crucial to the central limit
theorem and hence also very crucial for
the prgs
that design based on the central limit
theorem so the key challenge in this
work is to bypass this calcium middle
person not because we're trying to be
you know smart or trying to have better
parameters just by necessity so setup is
that we have M general LTS the weights
of a general half-spaces not necessarily
regular that's 8ax
it's not going to be close to a
multi-dimensional Gaussian if so I'm
gonna be close on the uniform it's not
gonna be close on a pseudo-random and
yet our goal of that of fooling the
intersection of half spaces defined by a
is exactly that of showing cooking up a
pseudo-random why such a a x and a y are
close in CDF distance so sort of the
conceptual challenge we have to do to
overcome in this work is sort of step
out of this framework of a central limit
theorems we'll still be using yeah so
sort of bypassing the gaussian middle
person
okay however even though so this our
result we will cook up a pseudo-random
why such a x and a y are CDF close
regardless of what a is just an
arbitrary a we will not go through the
Gaussian because we cannot however we
are still employ central limit theorem
based ideas in particular will use the
lindbergh replacement method sort of
very powerful and versatile technique
for proving central limit theorems it's
basically equivalent to the hybrid
method in computer science
we'll see that I am this is Mecca
Zukerman and Harsha Clements necklace
strategy for the whole regular case and
however since regularity is crucial for
the tech for the truth of the same and
is crucial for the technique we need new
I get ideas and ingredients two of which
are pseudo-random generators for CNF
formulas it is a very very well studied
class of formulas in pseudo randomness
and as I alluded to also a new high
dimensional that would offer a theorem
for polytopes
not sure if I'll have time to speak
about that but I hope I do
okay so this is a structure for the rest
of the talk and it's also the outline of
how our proof first I'll start with a
useful decomposition for polytopes
relating general polytopes with this
notion of regularity that I alluded to
give you this decomposition I like to
talk about a smooth version of the
problem for that I have to explain why
the current version is not smooth and
I'll tell you about the smooth version
of this problem I'll talk about proving
that smooth version which is really the
main part and I what I may or may not
have time to to go into and this is what
involves a little would offer at any
concentration in quality it's how to go
from this smooth proxy of the problem
back to the actual problem okay so let
me start with this useful decomposition
of polytopes again oh I'd like to try to
relate a regular half-space sorry a
general hospice with a regular heart
space a general polytope with a regular
polytope so what what's the what's a
regular half space it's a half space for
which the weights are spread out
nobody's too dominant a half space does
not have to look like this
the weights of the general half space
could look like this this is just a
single single half space
not a very difficult argument one can
show in fact that every half space every
arbitrary half space can be made regular
by just fixing a few coordinates I think
of this is literally a constant like 10
for this talk you can make every half
space regular by fixing a very small
number of coordinates it's not precisely
true there's a different case but in
some sense this is even better for us so
for this talk maybe just pretend that
every half space can be made regular by
fixing a small number of coordinates
okay so this is so here's the regularity
lemma in a in a picture if you give me
any half space
I saw the weights according to its
magnitude then there's a small number of
head variables one over epsilon square
and again for this talk just think of it
as ten after which the remaining n minus
ten variables would be very well spread
out so this is structure theorem for any
half space we're not dealing with a
single half space we're dealing with a
many half spaces but we can of course
apply the structure theorem to each of
the n many half spaces in our polytope
so one remark and again for each of them
think of it as literally ten or three
one quick remark I like to make is that
each of the heads are small each other
heads have size at most 10 however we
are dealing with and many half-spaces
which is more than n say N squared so
the union of all M heads could cover all
of them so there's a naive strategy here
which is to sort of like restrict away
all the head variables that's not gonna
work
when you're dealing with more than
enough spaces you cannot when you if you
restrict away all the heads you may be
left with nothing you have me you know
the first half space may have the head
being x1 second half space may have
their head being X 2 and so and so forth
so that's not what we're gonna do but
yet this this picture is still gonna be
useful for us we're not gonna reduce the
regular case okay so this all set up
that's what we have to solve we are
given an intersection of M arbitrary
half spaces and we're gonna look at the
weights as a matrix are M by n matrix
every row of the matrix we can highlight
a few variables that are large such that
for that role if you ignore the large
variables what you're left with is a
regularly uniform however the union of
all hits could still cover all and
coordinates and our goal is exactly the
show that given any such matrix any
matrix to cook up pseudo-random why such
a x and a y a close-in cdf distance and
this mental picture will be useful for
us and what's a why it's again the mecca
Zukerman harsha client's mecca a
generator with different parameters the
key is to prove that under such you know
random distributions was still good okay
so that's the decomposition of polytopes
next i'd like to tell you about a smooth
version of the problem which intuitively
on a technical level is easier to deal
with so in what sense is the current
version not smooth like to show the ax
na y RCT up close what does it mean to
be see there close it shows it means
then for every often well I guess
translator often defined by B so there's
an author and the probably that ax falls
in this author and it's roughly the same
as a probably there a Y falls in it
offand that's exactly what it means to
be CEO goes there's rewrite it I'm doing
nothing here just rewriting as
expectation of OB the often indicator of
ax
close to
a wife fed into often the only indicator
and a key that the reason why this
problem is not smooth it's because OB is
a discontinuous function it's one here
it's zero here and there's a many points
of discontinuity on the boundary it's
gonna be inconvenient for us so I'm
gonna work instead first prove this
theorem this closeness with respect to
not this zero one valued indicator but
like a smooth approximated to it now
it's a bounded value function and this
is in this line of work is sort of call
it sometimes got a multiplier and it's
completely standard it's yeah it's
appears in HK m and in Mecca zu combined
in the proofs or central limit theorems
so let me just say one word about what
this smooth approximator is it's a very
standard way of smoothing out a function
adding a little bit of Gaussian noise to
the function so there's a heart function
what does all total looked like well
okay we add some Gaussian noise there
are only two important properties for us
first is that we're like Oh toda to
still look like oh it should be a good
approximation at all and in and for our
purpose it's the following there's a
small error region unsurprisingly close
to the boundary such that you can make
errors but if you're far away enough
from the boundary you should be very
close to one like you should be and
you're if inside if you are far enough
outside you should be close to zero like
you should be and this small area region
you can go go from 1 to 0 that's the
first property and a second property a
technical property that that will have
and will need is that the this function
this smooth function has small
derivatives this the precise form of
this equation it's not too important but
roughly speaking for every order see
think of CS 3 or 4 the sum of partial
C's derivatives sum of magnet use at
most poly log M poly log n so I just
want to point out one surprising thing
which is that you're summing emptor to
see many things and it comes out to poly
log m and this is crucial in us being
able to get poly log MC length okay so
these are the two properties we'll need
and before moving on let me just remark
that these two properties are in tension
right to get the first one will like the
strip to be as small as possible to get
a better and better and better
approximator however input of Li the
small and smaller you make your error
region the derivatives are gonna get
larger and larger and larger so you have
to balance them out it's good that
they're in tension right so you have to
balance them out carefully okay so but
now we will walk it o tilde in circle
okay so good time let me talk about the
main part of the paper which is just
proving the smooth version and how to go
from the smooth version to the actual
version so I'll go to saloon not the
author indicator but often modifier so
this smooth function it cannot tell the
difference whether you feed it a X or ay
Y so what why is this you know pseudo
random variable when you hash things in
the buckets and every bucket
independently across buckets you fill it
in with our wise independence here's a
small of the observation of course you
can view a uniform distribution this way
also it's somewhat silly way of doing it
but this of course you can describe a
uniform distribution this way as well
Hessian in the buckets independently
across buckets use full uniformity
within each bucket but given this
picture a proof sort of suggests itself
you want to use the hybrid argument and
to go slowly from the picture on the
left to the picture on the right so
there's a bucket wise hybrid argument
also employed in in previous works I'll
start off with a picture on the left all
buckets filled in uniformly a uniform
string bucket by bucket swap out a
uniform bucket of bits for our wise
independent bucket of bits and argue
that each swap incurs small error and
today I'm just going to do an inbound
overall buckets so the last technical
part of talk I'm going to tell you about
how we bound error incurred just in a
single swap just think about starting
off with this and swapping out the first
bucket for bucket off our wise
independent bits okay so fix the bucket
all variables you start out with off
with a which encoded your weight matrix
over all n variables you can restrict it
to the variables in your bucket so these
are the variables that fall within
bucket B think of it as the first bucket
there's some large variables and if you
ignore the large bare and for every row
there's some large variables a few of
them almost ten if you ignore the large
variables everything else is very well
spread off and
goal is to show that you know you know
if you swap out this bucket a uniform
random assignment versus a pseudo random
assignment it's still close for this
bucket so the first thing I'm going to
do is to decompose a to the B which is a
restricted to this bucket B into H plus
D the head part and the tail part yes
ten yeah a small constant number no ever
you know it's like one over epsilon
squared even inch bucket yeah we can
only use very few buckets that's why
yeah because we are paying in depending
across buckets yeah so maybe yeah this
picture may be in this meeting it's like
one of epsilon many and then the bucket
slice is still roughly n it's like you
know all the end yeah yeah so it's a big
bucket yeah but if you know what the
small number of variables its regular
yeah it's a constant but it's not one
okay and I'm going to write eight to the
BS the head variables plus the tail
variables just the Sun but this is sort
of disjoint some so given this I'm this
is just nothing is happening here I'm
writing a to the BS the head part plus a
tail part and I'm gonna my goal is to
show that H X plus DX is close and
expectation 2h y plus dy with respect to
this test function this in this
distinguisher which roughly speaking
behaves like an author so every row is
sparse but every column we have a one it
may cover all of n okay just a quick
remark and here's where we start
deviating from central limit theorems
and on previous proofs the head
variables in a central limit theorem you
always assume that you're given either a
regular uniform or top of regular linear
forms so there's no head so everything
is a tail and so a you know every row is
regular and so the here's where we start
deviating from from here's where our
challenge comes in
okay so our goal is to show that HX plus
DX is close to hy plus T y with respect
to the distinguisher or tilde H T is the
tail variables there's a nice property
all the entries are small and spread out
this may not be true for te sorry this
may not be true for H but H also has a
nice property it is gonna be sparse
every row is gonna be sparse so you're
looking at the sum of h plus T where H
every row of H is sparse and T it's such
that every row is very well spread out
and your goal is to show that this
function that map's an input Z to all
total of HD + TZ you can be fooled so
cheesy is you know the entries are small
so you're looking at you know some of a
big thing plus a small thing sort of
suggest to use a Taylor expansion to
bound the error and a multi-dimensional
Taylor expansion the exact expression is
not too important but as we would expect
in a Taylor expansion that's a zeroth
order term there's a first order term
second order term you truncate it
somewhere you incur some error like we
show that in this Taylor expansion if
you feed in uniform bits for X for Z
versus pseudo-random bits for Z the
value of this Taylor expansion is small
so naively we could try to fool every
term of the Taylor expansion so as a
warm-up does it even fool the zeroth
order term of the Taylor expansion is it
true that each the hid matrix cannot
just the H of X and H of Y HX and hy are
closed with respect to old tilde and
again this is sort of our main challenge
because in previous works the proof is
very much similar but this was no op
this was a free step because H is the
constant zero function at trivially if
all the work comes in here but here even
in the zeroth order term we're starting
to see some of the challenges come up
when we deal with non regular linear
forms so let me in the rest of my talk
let me just stop by this this step
okay so there's no tail because we're
dealing with a zeroth order term so Z
maps to hotel they're off Hz where H is
a sparse matrix and although there's a
modifier for the autant and H has a nice
property that every row of H is sparse
so what so tell ya o tilde is a
approximator to the Ottoman and it's
obtained by adding a little bit of
Gaussian noise to the 0 1 value
indicator of the orphaned what's a north
end
you fall in an orphan if and only if
your first coordinate is at least
certain thing your second coordinates
and this is the sort of thing so
coordinated additionally this is certain
thing in particular you fall in authen
you find by B if your first coordinate
is a most b1 second coordinates most b2
and so on and so forth so it's a product
across coordinates and coordinate M
dimensions of some indicator of whether
you fall whether your threshold is
satisfied and I think in the product
depends on the 8th row of H across all M
and I throw of H sparse so every
function in the product all their M
functions and M is large but each
function only depends on a few
coordinates so this is a product of
hunters the end of interest and n of
hunters is is something we know in love
is a CNF formula and we're good at
fooling CNF formulas so combining the
product structure of all tilde which
really the product structure of Hotel de
is inherited from the product structure
of an author and plus the sparsity of
our head variables we can show that to
handle just a zeroth order term it
suffice as the full small with CNF
formulas and this is very very well
studied we have very good PR G's for it
achieving in particular when you're
dealing with an m-class CNF formula you
can achieve poly log m-seal and it's
simple but key idea is that we're
dealing with the product of K hunters a
products and n that's a with case CNF
okay so taking a step back our goal is
to show that we for the author modify
here we looked at this Taylor expansion
by the way the reason why we want to
work with a smooth function is because
we want to take the Taylor expansion
that's why we want to work with a smooth
function so get the zeroth order term
which we show that is connected to the
problem of fooling CNF s there are
intermediate terms it's more complicated
in the first in the first a zeroth order
term there's no tail variables right now
you're looking at the interaction
between the head variables and the tail
variables and you're looking at the ribs
but the key idea is the same it's the
product structure of now not the product
structure of all tilde but its
derivatives
but if all tilde has a product structure
and so does its derivatives it's also a
product structure HS parse and suffice
this force you'll random variable to
full CNF fabulous things are more
complicated now because they are two
variables but but the key idea is this
just a quick remark we are here we're
crucially using the fact that we can
full CNF to very high accuracy for say
the zip order you're dealing with M to
the C many terms we kind of do a naive
Union bound and because we can full CNF
to such high error we can afford to do
this so that was key for us yeah so we
fool the intermediate terms we truncated
a certain error and the way we deal with
the error is the same as previous work
perhaps not surprisingly because we're
dealing with the Taylor expansion and we
have to control the derivatives and this
was the magical fact alluded to at some
point which has all tilde is a good
approximated to oh and and yet it has
good derivatives so for the C power
error term is some expression depending
on the sum of magnitudes of the seat
order derivatives and yet it empty see
many terms come out to poly log n this
effect you - oh good it is due to
bankers
okay so what do we just sketch we're
dealing with the soft function the soft
modifier for the indicator function we
showed we were going to proceed by
hybrid argument then we showed how to
bound the error incurred by a single
swap and in fact that's how we bound the
total error we just take a Union bound
over all swaps okay that's my cue
all right time to wrap up so great case
let me tell you about
okay so let me actually show how to go
from the smooth version to the actual
version so what we have shown is closest
with respect not that often indicator
but some sort of you know smooth
approximation that often this
dysfunction is correct very close to
correct when you are sufficiently deep
inside authentic erectus you're
sufficiently outside often and then on
this often boundary you're making errors
you may be 0.5 when you should be one
and what we really want to show is
closest with respect to this heart
threshold you're just one inside and
zero outside so when are you in trouble
you're in trouble if you have a lot of
mass on this boundary so there's another
conceptual difference in what we have to
do in this step from going from the soft
to the soft modifier to the heart
threshold traditional proofs of central
limit theorem such as Harsha clients
Mecca they relight the synthesis since
they use the Gaussian as a middle person
this step follows from Gaussian aunty
concentration at the bounded mass that a
Gaussian places on on this often
boundary and in fact here there's a very
nice theorem of nazarov that gives a
good bound on this and this is what
Harsha clients in Mecca used to go from
smooth to hard for us since we're
bypassing the Gaussian so we cannot use
Gaussian at the concentration we have to
prove boolean and the concentration
which is formally even and he says it's
a harder task in a formal sense boolean
and the concentration implies Gaussian
and concentration roughly speaking
because every Gaussian is just a sum of
many moving bits so let me just tell you
about what we need we have to show the
ax where X is uniform random doesn't put
too much mass on Austin boundary so
let's forget about that and let's talk
about little would offer it which I
think we all know so it's the following
let W be a single linear form all it's
the the entries are all at least one
some sort of normalization and for all
open in the force of radius two that
probably did W dot X this linear form
falls in this intervals I'm most one
over Boonton and in fact so in
pictorially well W dot X is a discrete
sum but it imagined looks like this any
anyway you slide this interval with two
you catch at most one over root n of the
mass of the boolean mass in fact we know
exactly what the right answer is and
it's exactly pipe
when W is the hole one inspector so
here's what we need is a high
dimensional generalization of little bit
offered if you specialize everything I'm
about to write to M equals one you get a
little what offered so now instead of
dealing with one linear form we're
dealing with a matrix of M linear forms
normalized to have every entry at least
one for all
often boundaries this is our
generalization of an interval real
interval that's just the often defined
by B - often where every coordinate is
shifted by two okay for all often
boundaries can we bound probably the ax
falls in this often boundary so it's the
union of M dimensions you can apply
little would offer M times and take a
Union bound you can M over root n but
again we have we want to think of M s n
squared and to the 10th this is not a
good bound when M is what we are able to
show is that we get a good dependence
and damage and we prove root log M over
root n which allows us to take am being
N squared which we show is tight so they
don't offer it in equality where the
proof we you know our our weight matrix
may not satisfy this so we need various
technical chip extensions to deal with
the fact but this is really the core we
reduce to this this assumption just a
word this builds we build on and extend
techniques from a paper by Daniel Kane
which bounced every sensitivity of
polytopes this is related but not
exactly the same it seems like this is
slightly yeah well we recover his proof
as a special case yeah but of course
using his ideas and his techniques okay
so just a recap of the proof structure
we we have a useful decomposition of
polytopes relating this notion of
regularity with the general arbitrary
half space we talked about a smooth
version of the problem where instead of
dealing with like the zero one valued
indicator we dealt with a smooth version
of it we talked about to prove the
smooth version using hybrid argument and
you know using boolean NT concentration
going from the smooth version the actual
version
so just to recap our main result is a
Polliwog emceed length for the class of
emphasis polytopes or the previous set
Vesey length if you do not assume
anything on on the facets of the
polytope have linear dependence on M
equivalent is this a explicit set of
volume preserving points of size n to
the poly log M the most obvious open
problem is to improve on one of the
epsilon dependence our log and
dependence is optimal it's not the show
that you need at least log n dependence
you'll be very nice to get poly 1 over
poly log 1 of that stone and it's all
very closely related to issues about
convergence and central limit theorems
so it's very interesting for the reason
and the other less concrete directions
are there are the complexity measures of
polytopes
for example if you give me a sphere
there's infinitely many facets so you
know see length would be very bad but a
sphere is simple for some other reason
they appear just bought a geometric sets
other than polytopes can we give a PRG
for all convex sets
[Applause]
yeah that's basically why we're sort of
doing right limited in limited
randomness yeah
no we don't yeah it's sort of in denial
sis yeah we it's not it doesn't go into
a PRG at all it's like you fool you give
me any PRG that fools this booth often
modifier
yeah it sort of has nothing to do with
randomness yeah good question though
although I think we can also do your
enema is it for what it's worth what sir
thank Liang again
[Applause]